good morning millennials welcome back to
the morning toast happy monday hope
everyone's having an amazing day
yes happy monday wow fresh week fresh
week felt like a long weekend because it
was the holiday so we were just like
holidaying around and it wasn't really
like a weekend weekend
but i still i took the the rest
nonetheless yeah it was a very nice rosh
hashanah weekend it's a new year over
here
you know in the jewish calendar and
we're going to take that new year and
we're going to try and you know turn
some things around turn some things
around
turn the beat around so i hope everyone
had an amazing holiday if they were
celebrating it and if not i hope you
just like blacked out on your couch and
had a good time
um it was filled with highs and lows you
know
some news came out on friday night um
during the holiday that ruth bader
ginsburg had passed away a fellow jewish
queen
so we'd be rdh if we didn't mention her
memory being a blessing and you know
they say
actually that people who die this time
of year are like exceptional people our
father died like next week
yeah it's the time in between roshan and
yom kippur and this is also
the 10 days where the book of life is
being written so you want to be on your
best behavior
the book is open so is to be inscribed
in the book of life oh you know i forgot
that we're supposed to be behaving
right so just like think about that when
we report on stories la shanhara
maybe we'll be granting extra
forgiveness like lucky for you ellen
la shanhara is like what i struggle with
the most for those who don't know lush
and her it's like gossip
and it's like honestly one of the
biggest sins it really is like
it's it the the translation of the words
is like speaking evil so
i feel like where do we draw the line
between like sharing information
regarding someone else yes and la shone
speaking evil so i feel like you know
it's being like oh my god like jackie's
gotten so ugly like that's lush and hara
that's really [ __ ] mean oh you know
what i mean or but like do you just like
or you could say like
but me say i had gotten really ugly like
let's say something happened overnight a
curse was put on you
you could say wow jackie's appearance
has changed is that la shanhara i think
that's
fax dating that is just like the
communicating and spreading of
information
yes but speaking of jackie's appearance
changing it actually has changed a
little since friday
because on friday after the show we went
to dr sharon gizi's office to get some
injectables we were talking about it all
week and then we decided to vlog the
experience
right so if you're wondering what goes
down at dr sharon disease like how much
botox we use when we do it
claudia got her lips done i got some
insta lipo if you're curious about what
that all looks like
head to our patreon channel patreon.com
morning toast and check it out
it was really like informational i was i
was like asking questions while i was
filming just to like stimulate
conversation
but sharon casey is just a wealth of
knowledge and
honestly i'm so happy with the way that
i look usually after i get my lips done
the first week i hate it second week i
go into like a little depression then
third week i really
like it but i'm she did like the perfect
amount i'm so happy with how it turned
out
um and people are always asking us like
about the particulars like how much how
many cc's do we get
and we asked dr gizi all that so it was
actually uh turned out to be quite an
educational video
they should show it in schools they
should show it in schools and now my
forehead is in check
i'm saying and it's just so nice nice
however yeah
it's crazy when i was editing the video
like you filmed really up close and
personal like you really do see
the wrinkles i feel like i do a good job
on this show of like not letting my face
get super wrinkly and expressive
but those wrinkles are there and like
that botox is working ot
i love plastic surgery and i'm here to
destigmatize
and be transparent so um
go watch a video go watch the video but
also if plastic surgery is not for you
that's beautiful as well you know
that's the great thing about being a
human being like you can do what you
want
it's so beautiful and you know what's so
beautiful just like making your own
choices and like not judging other
people
that over the past few years has become
like my life's identity it's like
i don't care what anyone else does and
nobody needs to care about what i do
like
just [ __ ] off yeah i think that should
be like the new
u.s policy like everyone just [ __ ] off
claudia that's beautiful
i think i think i'm onto something you
know what else is beautiful
yesterday claudia and i went to zara oh
my god i haven't been in so
i don't think i've been in like two
years and we
did a major haul we should actually do
like a youtube haul that's how much
stuff we got
my shirt is from zara my sweater is from
zara and everything i'll be wearing for
the next three weeks like i could wear
something new every single day for three
weeks
and then be finished with my haul like
that's how much stuff i got so many
cardigans so many basics
like i feel like i'm always looking for
just a top like nothing i don't wear
like prints or anything so nothing
that's gonna like
shake up the world yeah just something
to cover my body
and zara really had it all zara is like
almost a perfect store like if they just
had a normal online shopping experience
they would be like a 10 out of 10 store
but with like all the confusing poses
and like all the big pictures and the
website like doesn't scroll
it is the worst website on the face of
the earth so they're like almost a
perfect store
yeah i guess it's a good in-store
experience we just grabbed everything we
didn't try on
um and it worked out well for you
because i also didn't buy anything that
like
i wasn't certain of the silhouette you
know like that dress i almost bought i'm
so glad that i didn't well
i had to return four items and you know
you could return at any zara and i live
right by one we went to one like far
away but
you can return to any isn't that like a
fabulous store policy that is a fabulous
store policy
and we saw a toaster i want to give her
uh oh my goodness shout out to you so
nice
she literally said the night we're
getting on the escalator to leave and
as we're like on the third step she like
comes and grabs our hands and she's like
she didn't touch her hands she touched
my oh okay oh i'm not weird like you it
was lovely i enjoyed it
human contact finally she said i just
want to let you guys know
you are the loves of my life and i was
like what did you just say it was
beautiful it was a beautiful moment
between steen so
aaliyah i think her name was thanks
thank you thank you girl
um so we have a fabulous show lots of
news i actually wanted to talk about
something
because we do have two big housewives
stories today and we did a lot of
housewives content on friday
and people are getting housewives
fatigued yeah and i thought that like
i was giving the people what they wanted
but it turns out that like we're not
like a bravo
recap show but like i thought that we
were so i think that some people
watching
are getting exactly what they want
people love when we talk about
housewives but not everyone that watches
our show watches housewives and i think
they
accept you know some level of housewives
chatter the recap
the recap and i think they just enjoy
hearing us talk about stuff so if it's
housewives or other stuff whatever
um but right now all these shows are in
transition like so not only are we
recapping them
but there's like news articles about
them and so it's definitely housewives
heavy but
these things are just cyclical and we're
gonna try and be aware of it but there's
like two housewives stories today that
like are the big stories of the day
and we have to recap potomac and i also
started new york from the beginning i
don't know if i mentioned that so it's
just been like
really top of mind speaking of my
journey on new york housewives i'm at
the point where there is the
break between jill and um bethany and
it's
it is so painful like i actually have
slowed down like i was watching like 10
episodes a day and now i literally watch
like two episodes the whole weekend
because it's so painful for me and
honestly i feel like i'm still taking
jill's side
even though i lo i love bethany like to
this day she's one of my favorite
housewives
i'm still taking jill's side have you
gotten to the scene in luann's apartment
no it's very new it's there's still a
fashion for me that is
like everyone was on jill's side but the
scene in luan's apartment where jill is
like
like running around like in the
apartment like she's being chased and
like luanne is is
by the way getting in between jill and
bethany like that's when i turned and i
was like oh
this woman is trying to apologize for
something that was like doesn't seem
unforgivable yes and jill has overplayed
her hand at this point and that is what
happens
that is what happened jill was kind of
in the right jill had a tough summer
with bobby and like
all this stuff was happening for bethany
and i don't think that joe was ever
really jealous i think like jill just
wanted to be a part of it like she's
she's like a yenta she like wanted to be
involved and i think bethany just like
kind of took off and like forgot a
little bit where she came from
and she's it wasn't it wasn't that big
of a deal
no but it turned into like this huge
thing yeah but it's just
it's really painful to watch i'm sorry
that you're going through that so i'm
sorry you guys will have to hear about
like all different sorts of housewives
news
yeah sorry but we we have other news
lots of ellen premiere today which is
kind of the biggest story yeah and the
emmys which we didn't watch but we have
some of the highlights and finally uh
shit's creek
got their comeuppance and we're very
thrilled about it let me tell you why i
literally did not watch the emmys
because for the most part um i really
like award shows emmys is probably my
least favorite yes
because i watch like trash tv and
unfortunately the emmys does not
recognize trash tv
that's true what do you like less
emmys are the golden globes oh emmys
i think the golden globes are first of
all a little bit more a-list okay
because they're movies
and music so like taylor swift was there
last year the golden globes are like so
serious it's like the definition of like
hollywood taking itself too seriously i
feel like the golden globes
actually does a good job of picking
hosts whereas the emmys is
always jimmy kimmel yeah you know i
actually like the golden globes way
better like definitively
but i always watch all the shows because
the red carpet is just like so
pleasurable
but there is no red carpet because of
chronovirus and i saw a couple networks
doing like virtual red carpets
and as much as i would literally like
take a knife through my heart for justin
sylvester and morgan stewart like i was
not watching that
yeah yeah i agree with that i didn't
watch the emmy it's not because of red
carpet even i just like
the way that it was set up after
watching the cmas where they did a
pretty
job and like yeah the acms and i i
actually felt for a second like i
like i forgot what was going on in the
world like the emmys made absolutely no
effort to
distract also there was like no
commercials for it
no i mean i didn't even know it was on i
knew it was on and i actively chose not
to watch it but then rebecca texted me
and she was like oh my god
moira won oh so i was like okay so i
went to the channel and then shit's
creek was just like pulling them all in
because we were in the comedy category
and then i had to go and watch real
housewives potomac so i got to see the
setup a little bit enough to know that
it was like really really bad
yeah but what i did think was
interesting was what from the clips that
i saw
i thought the most fun part was how
people were set up at home watching the
emmys like having nothing to do with the
actual production of the emmys like
people who were nominated were either
like alone in their houses
zendaya was like with her whole family
her whole team shit's creek like through
their own little enemies they all like
little tables
that i thought was well done and that
had nothing to do with abc or whoever
was putting on the show
yeah so i agree it was cute when like a
lot of the shows got together and had a
watch party together but like
it was still so sad like the shit's
creep party looked like it was at
the rosebud motel like no but i thought
it was so cute like
it was cute it looked like it was cute
but like it wasn't
you know imagine like this is your year
you went all the emmys and like you're
literally standing in a tent outside in
canada
yeah so anyways let's just if we're
going to talk about the enemies let's
get into the fast side stories that
you need to know before you wake up and
take a bite out of your morning toast
and jackie if i may i have a very
important announcement
not only i saw the doctor and not only
do i have a very severe case of rdh
i also have a very severe case of
morning breath so he prescribed me bruce
which is a genius honestly first of all
my favorite product to talk here about
here on the toast because i really
i literally used it this morning and
because bruce
so bruce is a fabulous electronic
toothbrush it's literally the sound it
makes
and it's millennial pink it's like so on
brand for us yeah you guys i used my
brush this morning i've been using
bruce since we got it and it's
incredible it's the best toothbrush
i've ever owned period hands down
brushing your teeth can be a chore but
brushing
is fun and it's 100 times as effective
bruce cleans your teeth at 31 000
movements a minute
manual toothbrushes do just 300.
many electric toothbrushes are barely a
step up for manual some do a good job
but for close to 200
or more bruce delivers premium sonic
wave technology without the markups that
big electric toothbrushes tack on
it's a fabulous product it is so
beautiful to like first of all
first of all have on your counter mine's
pink it comes in a few colors but it
just really elevates
the whole bathroom experience and whole
brushing experience it does and you see
such a visible difference you feel a
visible difference and it's just
the best electronic toothbrush because
it's not crazy expensive
but if you want to get 15 off you're
bruce you can use promo code toast
at bruce.com brucia spelled b-r-u-u-s-h
again 15 off your bruce bruce dot com
promo code toast try it 90 days
risk-free and get a two-year warranty
at bruce b-r-u-u-s-h-dot-com
promo code toast the bruce kit includes
the electric toothbrush
three extra brush heads magnetic
charging station and a sleek travel case
um which is fabulous because ben can use
it too because we have two heads
love it okay well first story shit's
creek sweeps the emmys is a night to
remember daniel levy says
after years of critical acclaim and a
growing fan base shit's creek has
finally won its first emmy and then some
first the show took home two statuettes
at saturday's creative at arts emmys
ceremony and then last night at the
prime time awards
catherine o'hara aka moira rose one
outstanding lead actress in a comedy
series
eugene levy one outstand lead actor in a
comedy daniel levy one outstanding
supporter
supporting actor in a comedy and annie
murphy one outstanding supporting
actress in a comedy
in total shit's creek won nine
emmys last night setting a new record
i just find it so crazy that moira and
johnny rose are considered the lead
actors and alexis
i too find that interesting and david
are considered the supporting i would
think that the show's actually more
about the kids than it is about
the parents i would think so too but
fabian for me
to say who is the lead actor what's that
from that's moira
oh oh my god did you see moira's
acceptance fees no
it was as if moira rose literally won an
emmy we would expect nothing
what was that movie she was working on
crow's crow's nest
it was as if she won an emmy for crow's
nest she did
and was giving a speech like she was so
moira and i don't know if it was just
catherine o'hara like giving a nod
to the excellence of moira rose or like
like life means art and this is who she
is
right i mean it would have been like an
amazing method acting thing to like
literally accept the award as moira rose
because
the character moira like her winning an
emmy is her life's dream yeah it's not
that far she is like a z-list celebrity
like it could have happened
um i mean this is so fabulous i feel
really proud that like
i actually been watching shit's creek
since season one like i'm not i never
had to binge i'm not like a bandwagon
and it was it's it's just an amazing
thing where it's like the show is not on
a primetime network it's impossible to
watch
until it gets on netflix like i don't
have pop tv
some people have it you have it on
youtube tv it's like a random ass
channel
yeah so to get so so much critical um
acclimation
and all these awards is all you can hope
for as any show especially show that's
not even on a real channel
yeah they really started from the bottom
and now they are here and it
with their final season it's nice that
they finally got all the credit that
they deserved i was just hoping for at
least like one emmy so that shit's great
could be called like an emmy womening
show and i hope
that one emmy would be for moira but for
everyone to have won
like really a beautiful end to the
shit's creek story i haven't watched the
final season it's like something i'm
saving so hard i completely agree i'm
saving it as well i definitely saw some
spoilers like that oh you did
not i mean it's hard with spoilers it's
not a show about like what's going to
happen next it's just like
a show about where we are now and how
are we going to make it a funny
situation right
like do the roses get their money back
and then like build a palace in [ __ ]
so we spoke about this like a while ago
of course someone like had to spoil it
for me and
i don't spoil please don't you know i
tried to put it on my bed as
my head as best as i can okay so i like
i know some stuff but i don't
really know i feel like now shit's creek
is like in the news like if i don't
watch it soon like it might actually get
spoiled for me maybe that's what i'll do
today yeah i've just been holding on to
it like
for like a really long plane ride like
something where i just really really
need it
that's good for a really long plane ride
like maybe we have to take a trip just
so i can watch it's creek
yeah i'm i'm so down for that yeah um
i'm just i'm so happy for moira
also something weird i'm watching love
island and one of the contestants names
is moira
what is she 97 years old no she's like a
vibrant young
thing and that's crazy so crazy but now
it's like
so normal on the show and it's like
it's it's so crazy that's insane it's
insane
yeah i hope she watches shit's creek i
hope that um
i'm just curious like is moira rose
really like who katherine o'hara is or
is catherine o'hara
o'hara the greatest actress of all time
you know what i mean i just feel like
there's no way that catherine o'hara is
in moira they have become one
so it's like either she just is who she
is and played that character on tv
or she is probably the greatest actress
of our time i think it's a little bit
of both you know i think that catherine
o'hara has some moira in her but i also
think that we all have some moira in us
definitely um but i think that moira is
you know
an extreme version of something that
katherine o'hara like might have inside
of her
yeah you know what the character with an
incredible vocabulary
incredible you know who the character
kind of reminds me of in a sense that
i feel as though they were a breakout
star from like their their show
and um to me that person will always be
their character
titus andromedon like they give me
similar vibes where it's like
whoever the brainchild of this character
was like is a genius
and whoever put titus burgess in this
role is perfect because no one else
could have been
titus andromedon and maybe the show
wouldn't have been what it was without
titus
burgess and without catherine o'hara
like that's how i feel yeah and it's
like
everything that comes out of their mouth
is a beautifully scripted
hilarious joke that was written by a
genius yeah i agree with that
and like they oh it never cease to not
make me laugh it's very true okay now
i'm like
missing shit's creek i think i'm gonna
go take the plunge soon yeah honestly i
kind of want to start from the beginning
and watch the whole thing
through mm-hmm it's an easy show to
binge the episodes are short there's not
that many episodes in a season
um now i'm on real housewives of new
york where it's like 20 episodes and
they're each an hour
24 hours that's a lot there's not even
that many episodes now
bravo like started 10 episodes and then
when the shows got really popular was
like 22 24
and now they're at like 15 to 18 which i
think is a reasonable amount that is a
reasonable amount but here are the
the other emmys 2020 winners hope your
fave won
outstanding comedy series shit's creek
outstanding drama series
succession don't watch i don't watch but
people are obsessed with it see i only
watch shit's creek i don't watch
any of these shows i've now tried to
watch succession i think twice where i
like watch the first episode and a half
and like i can't make it past that point
it's so strange it is what it is
outstanding lead actor in a drama series
jeremy's strong succession
outstanding lead actress in a drama
series zendaya euphoria
big deal this is a big deal only second
black woman to ever win in the category
and now she's the youngest person to
ever win because she's only 24
and she had her whole family behind her
and they were like literally just
sobbing but here's what i was thinking
there was an emmy in the room because
some guy brought it
up to her it's like did she know i
watched her reaction video because it
was so
sweet the person who brought it up to
her probably like
had her address and knew that's where he
was going he looked like a member of her
team like he was literally
celebrating with everyone oh well then
maybe like someone gave it to someone on
her team and like hit it
i don't know yeah the guy was not in a
hazmat suit
i saw the hazmat suits that were
delivering awards
but i don't know i'm just going to tell
you
everyone was surprised yeah because
that's the best part of an award show
like seeing people
surprised and then like when they don't
win it's like oh yeah
i'm so happy you know yeah outstanding
lead actor in a limited series or a
movie
mark ruffalo i know this much is true
literally never even heard of it
yeah no hugh jackman bad education
should have won
fabulous movie i know we've spoken about
it but i can't recommend it enough or
paul mezcal normal people or jeremy pope
hollywood yeah
paul mezcal hollywood
winner normal people what did i say
hollywood
paul mezcal normal people winner
outstanding lead actress in a limited
series or movie regina king
watchman i love regina king so much i
only want positive happy things for her
like every award
she has to win outstanding lead actor in
a comedy series eugene levy shit's creek
outstanding lead actress in a comedy
series
catherine o'hara she's creek outstanding
reality competition
rupaul's drag race rupaul's drag race
they win every year it's like
you know it's like not even a big deal
for real like just so many emmys so
little
time um but i just absolutely love like
the
the winning and just like the overall
success of the franchise world of wonder
i'm so happy for everyone
um it's fabulous oh and by the way he
gave like he dedicated the award to
chichi devine who was on a few seasons
ago and recently passed away
really really sad like such a young star
really really sad
that is really sad outstanding variety
talk series last week tonight with john
oliver
really are we sure about that they're
all the same like what are the other
ones
daily show with trevor noah full frontal
samantha bee jimmy kimmel live late show
and stephen colbert like
like they're all the same except for
samantha bee who's like the only woman
but
um i don't have a horse in this race i
get no me neither but i guess like
they're all the same like
who's do people like the most and i
guess i would say john oliver
yeah people do like john oliver and it's
like unique and he's like funny and
quirky like with his glasses so i guess
i'm happy for him outstanding limited
series watchmen
i'm just oh unorthodox was there didn't
win
oh that was really good little fires
everywhere didn't win
i didn't like it no me neither
outstanding supporting actor in a comedy
series daniel levy shit's creek
supporting actress in a comedy series
annie murphy's shit's creek
outstanding supporting actor in a drama
sillies series
billy crudup the morning show oh they
got to win an emmy
outstanding sporting actress in a drama
series julie garner ozark people love
her
um and then i just don't watch a lot of
these shows which is so crazy because to
me it's like
nobody knows more about like pop culture
film and tv than me
but i guess i don't really watch like
critically acclaimed shows i watch a
couple of these shows i've seen on
orthodox i've seen shit's creek
um rupaul's drag race but i don't like
watch like ozark or succession or fancy
like gray tv shows and i think that's
why we didn't watch the emmys because
when we went through the nominees we had
this same we came to the same conclusion
that like we don't watch these shows um
titus burgess was nominated for
outstanding supporting actor in a
limited series or a movie
abdullah mateen from watchmen won i
don't even know what that is
and then um sporting actress in a
limited series or a movie was uzu abu
aduba from mrs america i never saw it
but she is a phenomenal actress and then
outstanding variety sketch series snl
i don't know i feel like if there was
ever a year for us now to not win it
would be this year
by the way who else gets nominated in
the sketch comedy category
a black lady sketch show and drunk
history oh only three nominees
that's so little sketch comedy is a
dying heart ariana maddox must be really
upset yeah or maybe this is a good time
for her to get involved
i mean it's a good time to start a
sketch comedy show yeah
sketch comedy is like fun it's like camp
like skits you know yeah
it is fun so those are emmy winners
congrats to all the winners and the
yummies it's an honor to be nominated
yeah not like this year like it's not as
glamorous but you still it's good to
like keep the award so it counts
yeah it still counts yeah i'm just glad
like i didn't win miami this year
because like it honestly would have been
like a lot down
i totally agree i'm thinking next year
yeah
um next story another really big story
of the day ellen degeneres is addressing
the controversy in her season 18
premiere so
we had spoken about like whether or not
we thought she was gonna address this
and at one point
the story was so big like how could she
not but she wasn't set to start her new
season until september so like
honestly i had like forgotten a little
bit about it and
i was still really shocked that she
addressed it because even
in the whole [ __ ] storm we never really
heard from like ellen or her team it was
always like warner media and
all these like fancy statements yes so
she
um did her monologue for her show today
addressing the investigation and the
um allegations made against her show and
and you know the allegations meeting
against her that she is not a nice
person
and she dressed it like on a serious
note and also on a light note she
definitely incorporated
some jokes which i found to be actually
really annoying
um she was reading from a teleprompter
it was very much like
stand-up-ish almost yeah um and the only
other person in the room was twitch
because they had a virtual audience and
i think a lot of people were like
waiting to hear from twitch
he's become like a huge tick tocker like
him and his wife are
they like are amazing dancers and their
kid is really cute and they've just be
like blown up on tick tock
and i think a lot of people were like
wanting to hear from him and he didn't
really speak out and now literally he
was the only person on stage like
clapping so hard so
it's clear where he stands like stands
ellen
right so she apologized for her um
involvement
in things that transpired you know she
said her name is on the show anything
that happens at the show even if she's
not privy to it at the time like is
her responsibility and that
you know she's sorry for those things
and that they've taken the actions to
remedy and change and fix what's been
going on and that also this rumor about
her not being nice
even though she's the nice lady she's
like yeah
you know i am other things sometimes i'm
tired sometimes i'm sad sometimes i'm
mad sometimes i'm angry
impatient um and that she's gonna work
on those things
yeah i mean to be honest i feel like i
feel this way about like most
quote-unquote like cancellations is
people hate ellen and people love ellen
and i think the people that love ellen
were just wanting her to move on and
talk about it and then get over it
and the people that hated her like
they're not gonna think it was enough
like that's
really similar to how i felt about
stasi's interview last week it's like
people pretty much have made up their
minds and maybe this swayed them one way
or another but for the most part like
you either love ellen or you hate ellen
yeah i feel like watching this video i'm
not someone who either loves ellen
or hates ellen i i don't really care but
when i watched her
apology and just um addressing
everything it definitely like softened
my heart towards her because i
felt you know it it's hard to say
whether or not she's genuine like
she doesn't know but you know what she's
like she is an actress yes but like
she's apologizing
i don't know i just i i want to accept
it and move on like it's not for me to
accept because i'm not someone who
worked on her team and was affected by
her actions at all
but just as like someone like the
millions of viewers you know who aren't
directly impacted but have an opinion on
ellen
i just felt like okay i can accept this
and try and move forward as
as a viewer is it impartial yeah it's
just a bystander
and someone who comments on pop culture
like right i just
but that is who i am like every time we
have these sorts of
things that come up with like
celebrities saying something or doing
something or getting in trouble for
something and then like they apologize
you know unless it's a really half-assed
apology like i tend to
accept it and i tend to want to believe
them because i don't want to
like live in a world where people are
just stagnant
unable to change and become better
people and by the way i feel that way
about
these types of situations even when like
when most of the time it's like not on
us to accept the apology but like when
we were speaking about nick cannon it
technically was on us like he had
been really um had this podcast that was
very anti-semitic
and i feel that way even when it's about
me and when it's not about me like i
i hate being mad at people like i really
do and i don't i
i feel like i used to but i really don't
now see bad in people like i
always feel like i want to give people
the benefit of the doubt and to go
on a tv show and just like after all
this has happened to ellen and so many
people were talking about her
and we never heard from her like she
honestly i feel like she could have
slightly gotten away with doing less and
she didn't so
i'm just i'm not in the mood to
assume people have hate in their heart
you know yeah or that people aren't
capable of change like that's just not
what i want to believe about humanity so
i choose to accept people's apologies
and as far as like she could have done
less i i agree
she could have breezed over it a little
actually i don't know if she could have
gotten away with that but she also could
have done more like there was no one
there
who was interviewing her like asking her
questions in specifics
you know it was scripted and
that's actually very very her terms she
didn't have to answer
any direct questions it's actually a
really good point now that i think about
but i'm not saying that that's what she
she necessarily needed to have done like
a sit-down interview
everyone goes about it in their own way
and this is the way that she thought was
best and
i thought i thought it wasn't bad i
really didn't yeah i guess i just have a
hard time reconciling like
all these things about ellen because
like of what else we know about her just
like her being
like the first openly gay woman on
television and she got that medal of
honor from obama like
i don't know it's it's confusing but i
think that's exactly what she's saying
like she is that person like she can't
go on her show every day for 17 years
and act her way through
a talk show like yes she's a good
actress but like that's
she's not that good you know like that
at a certain point like
you know your mask is going to slip yeah
but i think she's that person she's a
good person she's a trailblazer like she
fights for
things that are important to her and she
helps people but she's not a saint
right and just like most people like
maybe she could be mean yeah
and yeah i don't know how to reconcile
all these things there's so much going
on in the ellen
universe yeah i just props to her for
like coming back
and she could have easily not and she's
so wealthy she doesn't need this show
yeah she doesn't need to continue to put
herself like in the arena and have
people like
talk and and throw and and just that's
true you have to defend herself
but she did it she's committed to making
this season the best season ever and i
completely understand that feeling
yeah i think that a lot of people
actually don't always agree with us when
we speak about like
certain can i hate to use the word
cancellation but i don't know what other
word to use
certain cancellations because my
instinct is always to
kind of kind of take the side of the
person who's being questioned
because i've been questioned and i know
how much misinformation is being spread
and i know how misunderstood i felt
so my natural instinct even if it's not
the right decision my natural instinct
is to always like believe the apology
wait
and that's because there's something
that's also your instinct is to believe
the apology because you
know what it's like to apologize and
that you are sorry so yeah
you believe that someone else is sorry
because and i myself
was yes yeah i don't know and i know
that it's not always
well it's actually not really ever the
popular um
opinion to have because i think people
like really do love like a pile on and
when there's all this all these
allegations against ellen or someone um
it's just easy to like to hate them and
i totally get it
but i know what it's like to feel so
misunderstood so like part of me is
always just like i don't even like ellen
like that's the thing like
i actually think she's like like i
actually i think she probably was mean
you know
um but i don't know part of me just
always instinctively takes that person
aside and it's not because i excuse poor
behavior
or i think that it's okay to have a
toxic work environment
but it's really because like i do
believe people make mistakes and i do
believe
just because you're famous doesn't mean
we shouldn't give you grace you know
yeah and that's just my opinion
no i i agree so it'll be interesting to
see how everyone else
reacts and i'm sure we're not in the
majority no i haven't like read any
like tweets or seen what people are
thinking i'm sure you guys will let us
know
i just know how i felt when i watched it
and it was like it's kind of sad
yeah just okay let's see yeah and if you
don't like ellen and you can't
move past what you know about her then
don't yeah then don't it's really that
simple
right it is a free country you can
choose ellen or you cannot choose ellen
and i'm not choosing ellen i'm just
choosing to believe that she
is sorry yeah um okay let's move on
because daily mail is reporting
excellent breaking
news this morning breaking news and it's
not like
certified but i feel like i don't know
why daily mail wouldn't
be getting this right with housewives
like they're usually right yeah it's
either daily mail or page six someone
has the exclusive
uh honestly if i saw a headline i'd be
more likely to believe it in daily mail
than page six
i think so too but they're saying that
teddy mellencamp is to be axed for real
housewives of beverly hills
after three seasons after being branded
as quote boring and stale
teddy is being dropped from real
housewives of beverly hills a production
insider reveals exclusively to
dailymail.com
the 39 year old star joined the series
in 2017 and starred in series in seasons
eight
nine and ten a production insider told
dailymail.com that teddy is quote boring
and stale
and the other cast members don't
particularly like don't particularly
like her wow i can't speak today
she was blasted for her all in health
and fitness program last week after
concerns were raised by anonymous
subscribers about the unhealthy and
restrictive diets
well i'm not sure like what if that
really has a lot to do with her being
fired but i think
to be honest the the audience just
doesn't like teddy like and i don't
think they've liked her for a while
and you always have to give people like
a grace period the eileen davidson grace
period where it's like
you never know who's gonna go from being
disliked
to universally loved like derrick kemsey
was not liked her first season
we gave her another season and now she's
like a lot of people's favorites but
teddy never had that
wave turn for her like i i don't mind
her but people are very outspoken that
they think she's boring and that they
don't like her
um so i could totally see a world where
she would be fired i just think it's
interesting that like you can come off a
season of really being like integral to
the storyline like she was the one
really moving pieces
with lisa and with um kyle
about the denise brandy thing but it's
crazy that you could be really at the
center
of the drama and like maybe still get
fired i don't know i agree with
uh i'm lisa vander pump she was central
to the story
this season though she was in a place to
be central to the story
but just like completely dropped the
ball and the way that she even like got
involved here and there was like
not weak was yeah was extremely weak
um and really left it to be on brenna
and then
kyle and then her and so
i i kind of understand this decision it
doesn't really seem like a shock to me i
i don't think there's anyone who really
like love love loves her and then also i
don't think there's anyone who even
hates her like
people are just indifferent and it's
weird that i think is the worst place
you could be in
because at least like when you're in
that villain role and people hate you
like
you are contributing you are part of
your dream yeah yeah you're being spoken
about but i think that like
it teddy barely made her mark this
season and maybe it's because
she was pregnant and just like you know
wasn't getting super
into it because she too is busy but i
guess they're not going to give her
another chance like yeah
to get into it i also think like taking
her out of the group
really wouldn't affect the group that
much and that's when you have a problem
right i actually think if anything like
kyle would become a lot closer with all
of the other women i think
her friendship with teddy while it's
really really nice does keep her a
little bit
out of like on the sidelines um
and she used to be really really close
with kyle and dorit and it just
kind of has taken a back seat so i think
it's it's
interesting and i do think that this
report by the daily mail is
very possibly true yeah so when i
imagine a world
of real housewives of beverly hills
without teddy mellencamp it remains
unaffected which is
yeah so i don't know
i she and she's really nice and yeah
she's a lovely woman she contributed a
lot to the show and she was instrumental
in the takedown of lisa vanderpump
but you're only as good as your last
season yeah it's like football
yeah well we'll see in the following
days weeks
if this ends up being true yeah also in
regards to her all in
oh yeah the drama surrounding her
company a bunch of people have spoken
out just about like that the
the program is not super healthy and
it's very restricted it's very
restrictive and it's not
like technically um dietitian approved i
don't know of enough about
diets clearly um or this particular
drama in general to speak on it but
i just would say that there's nothing
that i read
that went against what i thought all in
was yes that's the thing it's like i
actually know two people who have done
it and this is exactly what i knew it
was like so restrictive
lots of working out texting that's like
now it's like all this texting and
hounding is like you know
aggressive and it's coming like off as
you know they're being so
crazy but it's like no that's what the
program advertises she's literally
accountability coach like that is her
strong suit is like sending you text
every day and checking
you so we could talk about whether the
program is good or bad
i'm not a judgment because we're not
experts on this
but what i will say is that like that's
exactly what i thought the program was
when she came on the season season one
and then
some celebrities had been on the program
and that that it's a low amount of
calories per day and it's a lot of
checking in like that's
yeah so i obviously don't know enough
about diets like foreign opinion on
whether i think this is healthy or not
because i'm not a registered dietitian
um but i've known for a while and i
thought maybe everyone did that like
this is what the program was
and it's for people who can do it and i
literally could never
yeah but i've always known that this is
what it was
so maybe i'm just not surprised because
i knew and maybe not everyone knew but
um again i'm not in the mood to get into
like diet drama like i have so many
other issues in my life
yeah that the diet world is just gonna
have to survive without me and they've
survived without me for a very long time
they have yeah they have but i don't
know how much longer they can go without
you i don't know they're holding on for
dear life
okay next story very exciting casting
news for real housewives of new york
they appear to have cast their first
black cast member
bersean shaw the real houses of new york
may finally start to reflect the
diversity of the city
motivational speaker bershon shaw is
rumored to be the next woman to hold an
apple
when mahoney returns for season 13 tmz
reported on friday yes i heard that they
have already filmed
oh wow a little bit so i really hope
that this is like true and not another
like rachel ukatel
right no no 100 moment i am
so here for this i just need to know you
know i have a very low bar when it comes
to housewives like are you rich
yeah and is a motivational speaker rich
i don't know i think
there's a lot of potential i think
there's a lot of money to be made in the
in the space
yeah it's it's a big industry a source
close to production told page six that
shaw
has filmed with some of the cast but
nothing is official yet so i'm sure like
they're maybe seeing how it's going but
she's on camera
that's a fabulous fabulous step in the
right direction
i am so curious at the most recent um
new york reunion they spoke about how
when bethany left she gave a list of 30
people and production does their
research and gets lists put together
i would just love to see that list like
who is on it
yeah no and it's so interesting that
that that's how it goes down like and i
i guess it's because bethany
is a friend of andy's and you know
highly respected on the show because i
don't think when dorinda left like she
left a list
no but also when bethany left she left a
gaping hole in the show and i think she
wanted to do everything to like leave on
good terms and
make up for it yeah and bethany i mean
leah is really like a mini bethany no
she's a she's a bit of bethany in
training yeah so it was really was a
perfect replacement
yes it was crazy how durana got like so
riled up about
the way that leah said you know tinsley
brought me onto the show and she's like
it's bethany also bethany and derinda
are like hanging super close right now
and so and that's what ramona like was
saying
madness that like bethany's in her ear
which is like disappointing for bethany
yeah i totally agree
like you are who you associate with yeah
and dorinda is unfortunately nothing of
the sort
yeah okay fifth and final story a little
good news for lala kent and randall
emmett who have revealed the sex of
their first
child and it's a girl so
sweet i mean she like showed up to her
gender reveal wearing biker shorts and
looking so snatched
and i just love lala and randall
randall also looks like he's lost a ton
of weight he looked so like happy and
healthy
and i forget that he has two other kids
so it's like not as big of a deal but
for lala this is like huge and he has
two daughters
so they're just going to be like he's
such a girl dad
yeah it's i i really like them like it's
it's so funny like where we've come
when it comes to la la and randall like
when she was driving the range rover and
like everyone was like who paid for it
and there was like a bunch of rumors
online that it was like an nfl player
um and now we're here they're like you
know getting married and having children
and it's just
it's really crazy how much vanderpump
rules has changed in the last
year yeah six months yep two of the cast
mates are pregnant
four of them have been fired like it's
just crazy it's crazy i'm really happy
for
lala it's such an exciting time and i'm
just really curious to see
what the future of the show is yeah i
don't think we're gonna get an answer on
that for a while
and i don't really care yeah me neither
um
i don't care about anything this morning
like just i'm just not in the mood to
care
yeah and you know what it is it's like
whenever i come up with like a really
strong opinion which is never
like whenever i come out with like a
strong opinion like people yell at me
that they don't like my opinion like i
can't take that so i just
my opinion from here on out is i just
don't care unless it directly affects me
right but also maybe it's like because
we're in like the 10 days between roshan
and um kipper you're just like trying
not to care about anything too much
because then you might say something
like out of turn
with all your passion maybe maybe you
know i have so much passion yeah you
really do
um okay so let's dive into our tv recap
we're going to be recapping real
housewives of potomac which is of course
brought to you by stamps.com
as we slowly adjust to a new normal we
still need to be smart about how we do
business
luckily there's stamps.com to make
things easier thousands of small
business owners
have discovered the benefits of
stamps.com in recent months including us
here at the morning toast
they've been able to keep their
businesses running and avoid the crowds
at the post office all from their own
computers
with stamps.com you can print postage on
demand and avoid going to the post
office
so you'll save money with discounted
rates that you can't even get at the
post office with stamps.com
they also offer ups services now with up
to discounts up to 62 percent and no
residential surcharges
so they bring all the mailing and
shipping services of the post office
right to your house in the comfort of
your own home in front of your computer
um whether you're a small business
sending invoices or an online seller
shipping out product
or just working from home and you need
to mail stuff stamps.com can handle it
all with ease
so now you don't have to risk your life
going to the post office and the post
office even before the pandemic was a
miserable place to be
so stamps.com is the perfect place to
use
um it's a no-brainer because it saves
you time and money like we said with
exclusive discounts
five cents off every stamp and up to 62
off usps and ups shipping rates right
now our listeners can get a special
offer that includes a four week trial
plus free postage and a digital scale
without any long-term commitment
that's at stamps.com click on the
microphone at the top of the home page
and type in toast
that's stamps.com enter toast at the top
of the homepage
thank you stamps.com for sponsoring
today's episode and let's dive into
potomac recap
let's finally we get to the episode
something happened
not we didn't get like the actual meat
of the fight but i felt satiated with
the michael
and ashley stuff and we got the build-up
of the fight so we know
why there is going to be a physical
altercation and so we're
feeling like we can take a side well
i i love monique and i don't like
candice so i'm inclined to take
monique's side but it is my
understanding that
i'm i'm inclined to take money inside
but it's my understanding that monique
is the one who
took it who put hands on hands on first
and
that's kind of unacceptable even if
someone is like provoking you but drag
me monique you know like yeah
i get it but that takes it to a whole
other level
and if i'm being really honest like
monique was fake sleeping like you
you can't convince me yeah oh i really
didn't think so
because that's just like such a weird
thing to do she had been complaining
like
the entire weekend that she was so tired
she'd been working
so so hard on this weekend i think it's
a very strange way to fall asleep with
your legs up and your hands
closed on your belly like i just don't
know if people sleep like that
i don't i feel like maybe if she was
faking she would have put her head like
tucked her head away to look like more
dead
you know no it was just like a first of
all also
now that i'm thinking about it she was
laying on her back with her legs up
which first of all it's very hard to
fall asleep with your legs up
also her hands were clenched which is
also just like a weird way to fall
asleep
and then her neck and her posture were
so perfectly up when like you fall
asleep you're actually your head kind of
tilts to the side
i'm never been more sure that she was
not not asleep i think she was asleep i
didn't give it like too much thought i
just assumed that she was asleep but now
that i'm thinking about it like i really
do think she was asleep because
she had candace in her home like and her
husband
all of this just to like skip out on
saying goodbye to her
yeah i mean she said goodbye to everyone
except for candace and they had
literally had a fight the night before
at the fire pit so
i just and by the way i thought it was
funny i didn't think it was a big deal
but like she was totally fake sleeping
i did not think that she was but 100
but also even if she was and because she
didn't want to like have to be awkward
and say goodbye like
that's fine by me no by the way for sure
it's [ __ ] hilarious like
when i was watching it i knew she was
faking it i thought it was so cool also
when candace was like you were fake
sleeping
and monique was like what i mean maybe
monique is a good actress but like she
looked genuinely like she did not know
what candace was trying oh i disagree
wouldn't have known that like candice
tried to say bye barely
no i really thought that um she got
overly defensive because she was totally
fake sleeping
but regardless of who's right and like
to me mo and i'm not 100 sure but
candace on watched raven's live said
that monique was the one to escalate it
to like a physical thing
to me even though i love monique like
you automatically lose when you put
hands on another person
unless they're literally out here saying
the most vile i have a dumpster i have
to see it it was a dumb fight but
candace was being
so unannoying like she's just so
annoying it doesn't mean you could put
your hands on no but like
i have to see if it's like candace has
her hands in her face
and then monique i don't know when he
flips her hair a few times
and then it gets i have to see it but i
agree if
if monique made it physical first she is
in the wrong
by the way i don't like candace like i
can't stress that enough like even this
episode
her storyline is now about music like i
can't it's just so uninteresting like
last season when
monique was like i'll drag you pregnant
and all and now it's like drag me
monique like
monique kind of has to live up to the
fact that she's gonna drag candace like
if she backs down not i'm not confusing
violence sounds like you are
no but it's like if she if she backs
down it's like she talks a big talk but
like
she she wouldn't but honestly like walk
to me i i lose respect for monique when
she takes it to that place like
she is this like yeah but it's like fine
fabulous woman and that's not what
refined fabulous people do
i agree but if she didn't drag her when
she said she was gonna drag her
then she she was well that would be
taken seriously that was a question on
watched raven's live last night with
candace being like do you think you
provoked
provoked her by repeatedly saying drag
me money drag me and
candace is like like i guess yeah but
like she [ __ ] put her hands on me and
i have to
i have to agree with candace like it's
unacceptable and it's painful for me to
say
i love monique yeah but you can't
i have to touch somebody i have to see
the whole thing because also they put
the screen like really small with the
watch what happens livestream which was
a [ __ ]
weird thing to do when it's like the
pinnacle of the episode so i really
i couldn't get a good enough like slow
motion by play of what was going on
which is what i'm going to need
to judge the situation they have to stop
doing that now like with watch robin's
life from home they've started
to make the the screen smaller so you
can see like the
michael jack before getting to his chair
yeah it's so annoying yeah
so even though michael rappaport
actually had some very um good insights
on beverly hills he always has
great opinions he actually said what we
said he said the question was were you
surprised that denise didn't return
for the season he's like no and i
honestly like i blame lisa rinna
she just bullied denise this whole
season it's not even about what's true
or not it's just about the fact that
they were friends
yeah so i'm like finally someone says
what i agree with what else did he say
um they played this game like what the
housewives and he's like a housewife's
historian and he did not know
any it was actually so disappointing um
did he like candace who side was theon
in potomac they didn't do a lot of
potomac talk
actually um they asked candace just like
about
the fight and a lot about ashley's
marriage because it's so weird how
now in real life ashley and michael are
expecting another baby whereas in this
episode they're actually talking about
maybe not getting back together but
ashley kind of opened
a can of worms by saying our marriage
has had its own identity for a while
like
it seems like they've had this open
thing like yeah i was so
impressed with ash hundreds she just
does not hold back she's really an
incredible housewife because she has an
interesting personal life
she doesn't pretend to be something that
she's not you know obviously there was
no way of getting around this situation
and pretending like it didn't exist but
some housewives might have tried
you know 100 and not had this particular
conversation on camera
but she like bounced into the wine
tasting and was just
ready to share with her friends i
totally agree i actually had so much
respect for her
i thought the fact that they had that
conversation on camera was like actually
admirable
and and i liked when he said cut and
then they spoke to the producer and he
was like i have nothing
she was cute the producer was cupid and
he was like and i at first i was like
what are you doing cutting in the middle
of your scene
and he was like i have nothing more to
say we talked about it okay like we said
what we said please let us have dinner
and
the production guy was actually really
understanding yeah like we got it
like it was just so interesting and it
just makes me feel like that's how
scenes are filmed like
let's go to dinner we'll talk about what
we have to talk about and then we're
going to cut it
and enjoy our meal yeah so it was just
actually a crazy episode and i feel like
we've all had this like sinking
suspicion that ashley and michael
definitely have some sort of arrangement
and
absolutely no judgment but with all the
things that we know about them so far it
actually made sense when she said like
it's kind of open in the sense like
maybe she has to be there with another
girl but there was something there
um and michael obviously took it too far
and i just couldn't believe that she
opened up that much
about the actual casino situation and
then like the identity of her marriage
yeah it was admirable it was it was
extremely i don't judge i don't judge
no i don't judge either i think the
women are
glad that she's talking them about it
and i think she handled it in the best
way possible and
last week i said like how is michael
going to get himself out of this
situation to the point where he's
expecting another child and i actually
see how like it's not that he got
himself out of anything it's like
she has chosen to give him a chance
just because and she's chosen that
ashley's a lot younger than michael and
it's very possible she just like
wants to have kids and it's not really
so much about michael anymore but she
just wants
kids and i can respect that yeah i
respect her a lot
and me too it's crazy how like the
episode was so major
but it's not even like she just i feel
like the more you talk about
something the worse it gets that's what
erica jane says but also the more you
talk about something
the quicker it ends well yeah cause look
at denise she didn't talk about it for
so long and it became so big because she
like actually
maybe the rules are just different in
beverly hills and potomac because i felt
that denise talked about it every single
time she showed up and by time eight she
was like i'm done talking about maybe
yeah but in potomac if you address
something
the ladies will let you live yeah
they're very reasonable over in maryland
yeah very reasonable so i thought it was
um a good episode i loved everyone's
oh it was the first time like maybe this
whole season that um everyone looked
dressed appropriately
for a gathering fabulous ashley looked
fabulous karen hugher looked fabulous
everyone looked amazing
agreed and they were cohesive and they
looked like they were all going to the
same place
i agree 10 points for gryffindor
um it was a good episode and the rest of
the fight is next week which is really
what the whole season is
basically like centered around and it's
the climax of it all so that'll be
really exciting we have
oh no new york and beverly hills are
over no we have one more in new york oh
so thursday
new york and is that it when is oc
october 7th i guess
that's like next week okay crazy times
crazy we've got a week off you guys
we're going to try some housewives talk
we're in a transition period
we are very exciting i mean these are
the best franchises
so it's less exciting but well i was
actually thinking about how coronavirus
impacted the housewife schedule in
general and to be
to be fair like the best franchises were
protected potomac new york and beverly
hills
and the ones that are a little you know
lacking recently oc and jersey
um when does atlanta premiere i don't
know and dallas they're filming now i
think oh but dallas is like
everything is fine in dallas yeah
actually i don't know but
no but they're filming like they had
like someone threw a dallas themed party
like the show yeah
like stephanie and cameron were posting
and like
it looks like it's and you know there's
actually like so much going on um like
with porsha and just like in the black
community i'll actually be really
interested to see how they
tackle it on atlanta housewives because
how can they not
yeah so there's a lot to look forward to
it's never been a better time to be a
bravo fan
very true also um i caught up on love
island everything except last night's
episode so now i finally like
have allegiances and thoughts and where
do your allegiance is live this is where
my allegiances lie because it's been
it's been a long journey um and then
also i went to twitter after to hear
what everyone thought sworn it was like
so interesting
because everyone's like so hard on
johnny and like by the end of the
um by the end of all the episodes like
i'm so done with him like i think he's
so manipulative towards sally and like
the way that he was making her like go
and tell
benny there's so many people on the show
it's so hard to remember like and then
benny selly ben there's literally three
guys came in it's
benny bennett and noah oh gosh um
but it's the whole thing is so crazy
because pretty much like sally and
johnny have been like
the og like best couple so cute
and then they did this thing where they
sent the five guys to one house
and brought in five new girls and the
girl stayed in the house and they
brought in five new guys and steli and
johnny were like the most
legit couple like not gonna be tempted
by someone else but like johnny was like
hooking up with this other girl like
really going at
it and because everything airs on tv
like pretty much that night
now that these new three new guys ben
benny and benny came in
they saw what johnny did at the other
house whereas the other guys who just
like heard about it because
johnny told them but like they saw it on
tv like the camera's in the bed with the
sheet over the head so like
finally steli is like hearing what
really happened and i think she does
have to
end things with him because something
just like
went awry even though i actually really
like them um there's nothing cuter than
like sally and justine's friendship
like also justine like talks and just
tick-tock sounds oh i feel everything
it's like it's the eyes for me
yeah it's it's really so so cute that's
so funny
and um their friendship is so cute and i
want to talk about mackenzie really
quickly because she just got
spoiler alert sent home and it took me a
while to figure out how i felt about her
in the beginning i found that she was so
annoying and needy and like just
not helping herself in any way shape or
form but by the end like i really was so
impressed by her and like everyone in
the house was working against her it's
like when the boy
she was with this guy connor and and
everyone hated their relationship
because they were kind they were like a
little toxic because like
she was needy and he like was kind of
wanted to explore
other things but like he wouldn't tell
that straight to her so he would like
talk to other girls but like she didn't
know that he was feeling this way and
like he was really like gaslighting her
but he's a nice guy he's an accountant
like he should be in tax day does he
work at ernst young but he just like
i guess was not feeling confident enough
to have these tough conversations right
so when they went to the different
houses all the guys were encouraging him
to be with someone else to like
make a new connection and when she was
in her new house this guy came in
and they just connected immediately and
all the girls were like you're you're
you're a whole new mackenzie like
you're so like fun and we love being
around you and this is like such a
better relationship meanwhile the guys
were telling conor to get a new
relationship right when they both came
back like she came back with the guy
that she was with like she just was like
this is a better connection for me
and conor came back alone bye and the
guys were like
going so hard at mackenzie that what she
did was like so horrible like america's
gonna turn on her and like america
was like actually yeah no like she i
actually was so surprised and impressed
by her that like
she would even look at anyone else
and be open to that and not so like
crazy about conor when she knows it's
not like the best relationship for her
and so and then it turned out that the
guy that she did bring in like literally
right after he was safe on the island
like he started like he was done with
her and was so mean to her and literally
was like
using her worst insecurities against her
pretty much like
saying that he saw the show before he
came on because like they get to watch
the show and like
the way that she was acting was so crazy
and like he wants no part of that oh
and like he felt like she was starting
to like be that girl again so he was
like done and she
and she didn't even sit around and talk
she was like that was so nasty like
goodbye good day sir i said good day so
she wound up
like and then there was a moment where
she might have gone back together with
connor and like i actually would have
been really happy to see it but no
instead she went home and i feel like
she really went out like
in a strong way having had like a really
rough time and like it was just really
sad because
it felt like everybody in the house was
like working against her and like
telling conor he deserved better but
like
when she tried to go and find better
like she was the bad guy and so it was
just
it was tough it was it was sad to see
her go but um
it is what it is it's it's such a crazy
show i mean i
just think the turnaround time is so
impressive and i think it's a really
really good model and like formula
for a reality show yeah it really really
is i think that
um who's gonna win the whole show i
think that justine and caleb are the
cutest couple
and i think that they're gonna win i'm
really i hope that that i hope that
everything like stays as good as it is
i don't know you like never know with
these things right i feel like it's been
on for a while
well that's because it's on every day
yeah so it's just
it's it's really good i finally 20
episodes later like i have some skin in
the game
right it's exciting yeah i hope i wonder
if you guys are watching i heard there
was a toaster on
faith um what was she like the first to
go home no no she came in when the five
guys went to the new house she was one
of the five girls brought in
and she didn't make it back to the old
house like no one like brought her with
them
but she seemed really cool and i was
like proud to be a toaster
love to see it yeah um that's our show
anything else we want to talk about
before we wrap up
no i think that's all she wrote thank
you guys so much for listening to the
morning toast millennial morning show
where we deliver the past five stories
that you need to know every morning
monday through friday on youtube so if
you're watching this on youtube please
feel free to subscribe and give this
video a thumbs up we're also available
as a podcast anywhere podcasts can be
found so that's spotify itunes stitcher
public radio irv radio cast box
all the places wherever you listen to
podcast find us morning toast leave a
five star review about how beautiful
stunning and smart we are
we love you guys we hope you have an
amazing day we'll see you tomorrow bye
[Music]
goodbye